[Music]
all right yesterday we took a look at
the projected win totals from the sports
books in las vegas including but not
limited to caesar's entertainment the
official gaming partner of the national
football league we did a draft of which
teams we thought were most likely to
exceed
those projections so let's keep milking
that cow chris there's still plenty of
milk left in that cow we're gonna flip
it around today and we're gonna draft
the teams that we think will fail to
meet their projections which frankly is
a lot more fun than guessing which teams
will exceed so the one part that isn't
fun for me now i did win the rig coin
toss yesterday because there wasn't one
obvious team and there isn't an obvious
one today so i'll probably win the rig
coin toss again today so here's the part
where chris calls tails the coin gets
flipped it comes up tails most of the
time except when it's not obvious what
the first pick would be then maybe they
let me win it once in a while go ahead
i'm sick of your spiel every day with
that okay get older
deal with it are you calling heads cry
me a river justin timberlake okay tails
go ahead tails kristen
keep it going here we go oh baby yes
yeah shocker all right go ahead real
shocker here okay
um i think i'm going to lead off with
somebody very close to your heart
uh the minnesota vikings oh hello
minnesota your guaranteed win total this
year is nine games i disagree
i see under all over this i see in my
crystal ball mike florio still
complaining about kirk cousins in
december of 2019 still complaining and
blaming everything on him even though
i still think there's going to be issues
with their offensive line okay
yes i'm not necessarily sold on you know
the offensive coordinator some of the
improvements they've made to their team
in general this off season nothing big
they haven't do anything the greatest
thing is they got anthony barr resigned
that was good for them as a whole but
it's not necessarily an indictment on
the minnesota vikings who i think are
still going to be a pain in the butt and
very good but i just think the packers
will be better i think the lions will be
better and i don't think the bears are
going anywhere because i think the bears
are still one of the better teams in the
nfc when all said and done so i'm not
saying the vikings are going to go way
under but i don't think it's going to be
nine games i think the vikings are going
to be in eight and eight seven and nine
land eat that mike florio and your p
purple people eaters okay
one trend that we have seen during mike
zimmer's time with the vikings it's been
every other year they they exceed
expectations and make it to the playoffs
and this is a year where you know they
had a disappointing season they go back
to the laboratory they figure some
things out they implement them and they
end up being better the expectations are
far lower this year i think the table is
set for the vikings to exceed that nine
game win total i really do and and again
they just have to match it for you to be
wrong because you're saying that they're
going to be under it i think nine or
more is very realistic for the vikings
this year i think the packers are going
to have a harder time than we realize i
think the bears are going to take a step
back i think last year they benefited
from the fact that they were largely
overlooked i think the vikings can can
win more they were eight seven and one
that uh
and that was a disappointing season yes
this year they will be better than that
so i disagree with you as much as i want
to complain about the quarterback and
the quarterback may keep them from
winning a playoff game or going as far
as they could go in the postseason
getting there isn't going to be a
challenge this year i think they'll get
there and i think they'll get nine or
more wins all right my first one and i
got plenty i can choose from but i'm
going to start with one of the two nfc
finalists the los angeles rams who won
that game and went to the super bowl and
lost 13 to three ten and a half is the
win total for them yesterday you said
chris the 49ers are going to be better
than they've been under kyle shanahan i
think the seahawks are still going to be
a force and who knows where the
cardinals are going to be i think the
rams are going to take a step back this
year they're going to be more of the
hunted this year than they've ever been
todd gurley's knee has an arthritic
condition reportedly that's an issue for
the rams and i think that also the
longer jared goff plays the more he's i
don't want to say he's going to get
exposed but i'll say he's going to get
exposed i think it's going to be easier
to defend that system to defend that
quarterback we saw what the patriots did
in the super bowl and that's going to be
the template for all those teams that
are facing the rams this year they are
going to that now they can still go 10
and 6 and be under but i think they're
going to be under the 10 and a half game
projections yeah i i'm with you there i
think everything you made uh all the
points you made makes makes sense to me
i mean i do think the seattle seahawks
are gonna be improved i do think this is
the year of the 49ers you got to watch
out for them i think it's official you
know so i would say that yes uh i would
expect that type of season from the rams
i'm with you they cross my mind 10 win
season it's hard to duplicate what
they've done the last two years it's
hard to uh duplicate what you did last
year and of course it's a big letdown
when you do lose the super bowl and you
get that high and that close to getting
a ring and a super bowl trophy and all
that um you know normal human emotions
outside of the the new england
organization yeah teams tend to fall off
uh the year after a super bowl loss so i
get you there honestly i'm going to stay
right there with you though in the same
conversation and stay in the nfc
championship game i'm going to say the
new orleans saints and not necessarily
yeah i know you were going to go there
right i knew it i knew it i almost
picked him one because i was scared you
were about to pick them there but either
way yes i'm going to go with the new
orleans saints uh
a little bit because of what we just
talked about two years of crushing
letdowns i do think the nfc south
that cam newton if he doesn't have a
banged up shoulder last year i think
they would have been a pain in the butt
till the very end i think bruce aryans
and the tampa bay bucks are going to be
better and i and again the falcons are
talented the falcons were ravaged by
injuries maybe more than any team in
football last year where if they stay
healthy it's still an extremely talented
football team so it's not necessarily
that i just doubt new orleans drew brees
is a year older uh sheldon rankins okay
he's got he's not going to be full
strength you know until maybe later in
the year or something like that if that
because he tore his achilles heel in the
uh nfc divisional playoff game so
there's just things across the roster
that worry me a little bit another
defensive lineman is up for suspension
things like that worry me about the
saints i think they're like ten and six
nine and seven not saying they don't
make the playoffs but i think they're
they're a little under 10 and a half
this year and and my biggest concern is
drew brees unless he was secretly
injured father time is catching him and
that could be
uh it's going to be a challenge to get
the most out of whatever brees has i
think sean payton has the coaching skill
to put brees in situations where he can
succeed even if he's limited physically
he's got the brain he's got the reps
almost like peyton manning in that final
year i'm not saying it's drew brees
final year but it very well could be but
i think that's going to be a challenge
for the saints to get back to what we
saw last year and that's why i i agree
with you i i can't i can't fight i think
you made a better second round pick than
you made a first round pick all right my
second round pick and um
you know
i hate to do this because i was a big
believer in the ravens last year and i
picked them to go to the super bowl last
year yeah but at eight and a half it
ain't that and i i'm not comfortable
with this new offensive approach i think
once the teams start to see what they're
doing they're going to be able to shut
it down the way the chargers shut it
down in the playoffs last year eight and
a half wins with the steelers and the
browns in that division i think that's
too much to expect from the baltimore
ravens i think they're going to be under
the eight and a half projection and it
really hurts me to say it because they
were one of my super bowl teams and and
i really thought if they got to the
playoffs they could make some noise but
i'm concerned about this offense unless
they can unleash lamar jackson as a
passer more frequently it's going to
it's going to be a concern and the more
they run him the more likely he is to
get hurt and then they're going to be
down to robert griffin the third and you
ain't winning eight and a half games or
more if rg3 is your quarterback all due
respect yeah no i i hear you i mean i
like the ravens it is refreshing to
watch this kind of you know bludgeoning
run game style that they have but yes uh
you know with everybody having a gear
and teams in their division you know
they take weeks at a time to study the
other teams in your division to look at
the run game and things like that uh
yeah i guess i got to see a few more
tricks with the baltimore offense too to
see it expand lost a few players on the
defensive side of the ball but the big
point is what you said too the steelers
are going to be pissed off the browns
are going to be better and hey as much
as we question zach taylor and his
inexperience for the cincinnati bengals
man i challenge anybody look
look at the roster of the cincinnati
bengals still there's still a lot of
talented football players on there where
i just go they're not going to be any
cupcake that everybody's just going to
walk over so not a bad pick by you okay
and this is where i win the draft right
here um my third and final choice will
be the new york football giants uh and
yes their projected win total is six but
i think six you why do you hate the
giants i don't hate the giants i don't
hate the giants did your dad played for
the giants i love the giants shut your
mouth i don't hate the giants okay my
question with the giants is of course
the quarterback issue okay there's a
little issue there all right you know uh
i haven't necessarily loved some of the
things they've done in free agency but
my biggest concern with the new york
giants is their defense in general too i
mean the defense just has no difference
makers you know there's an issue there
you know they have janoris jenkins a
corner there's nobody else really proven
you know safety play i know they got
your real peppers but you know the
reality is the browns took jabril
peppers off the field in passing
situations last year so that's not
necessarily like an endorsement for a
safety who's going to be on the field in
passing situations there's no pass
rushers off the edge that's where i look
at it added with the aging quarterback
uh it just seems like they're more in
rebuild mode right now and yeah i think
the giants are going to be a 5 and 11
football team when all said and done
this year
yeah yeah
yeah i don't know this i find this
harder than picking the overs like we
did yesterday i'm more you know it's
funny yeah but when we were picking the
overs yesterday i'm looking at it saying
boy it'd be easier to pick the unders
and it was doing the enders today i'm
thinking man it was easier picking the
elves
i guess that means they did a good job
of setting the over under i got one more
though and um i'm torn between two of
them and i can say which two they are
since you don't have another pick i'm
torn between the broncos and the titans
here the broncos at seven with joe
flacco at quarterback okay and another
new coaching staff and some holes on
both sides of the roster and the titans
at eight and a half with the questions
about the quarterback position and it
hurts me to say it because i love mike
vrabe and i think he's going to do great
things as the coach of that team but
marcus mariota ryan tannehill i know
that you think tannehill could push
mariota and maybe be the starter i just
don't know with the jaguars and the
texans and the colts in that division i
don't know the titans can compete with
them yeah i don't think the titans can
and if they can't finish higher than
third in their division how can they win
more than eight and a half games it's
that simple i just don't i don't believe
the titans right now have the talent to
hang with a a division that has
systematically and quietly gotten better
and better and better yeah i i hear you
mike those are the team they were they
were on my short list of teams i wrote
down as well and yeah there's things to
like about the the titans roster you
know got a good secondary they've added
a few weapons at receiver but yeah the
offense is a big question mark i mean it
really is i don't know what to expect it
wasn't pretty last year with matt
lefleur until they finally figured out
hey let's just give derek henry the ball
every freaking play and see where it
goes from there but you know i don't
think that's going to be sustainable
going forward marcus mario the issues
he's had as a pocket quarterback all of
those things and then another team i
would look at and just go okay the front
seven there's jerrell casey and there's
some good players but is there enough
difference makers and that's where i
question it let alone like you said the
division is really freaking good uh so
i'm not mad at you that's a pretty good
pick
all right let's recap sims has the
vikings the saints and the new york
football giants as the teams that are
most likely to not live up to their
projected win totals by the folks in
vegas i've got the rams the ravens and
the titans we'll let twitter decide
who's right and who's wrong when we'll
return twitter's input on the
teams with the best young core of talent
for now and for the future more pft live
right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports